l'avocate et secrétaire général de
l'alliance des avocats pour les droits
de l'homme noémie saïdi côtier était sur
notre antenne tout à l'heure selon elle
moscou est légitime pour tenir sa
position face à la ligne etats unis
union européenne dans les côtes qui peut
être critiqué ce qui a pu lors de la
dernière conférence mis au jour c'est
vrai qu'il ya une espèce de discours un
petit peu de pensée unique c'est vrai je
suis assez d'accord avec ça avec ce que
serait la bien-pensance et où les les
les opinions dissidentes tombe avant
leur place alors c'est vrai que la
russie pourra tout à fait être en
contradiction avec le reste c'est une
bonne chose que d'avoir oxydé sinon je
n'imagine pas la russie plier je crois
qu'elle horaires définitifs n'ont pas
imposé mon cas arf et sur ce qu'elle
considère être sa fille et sa position
alors après quelle sera sa marge de
manoeuvre par rapport à l'europe qui
serait et poney ou cahiers dans cette
finition par les états unis
ce n'est pas exactement ça a été
compliqué sur façon à la france
contraignante que de cette décision là
on voit bien que 20 ans plus tard ne
trouve que sur la question raciale et
peu de choses ont changé